c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
soit il est bien menée sur france 24 à
la une ce soir le bras de fer entre la
cedeao et les militaires au pouvoir en
guinée l'organisation ouest africaine à
rejeter la transition de 36 mois
proposée par l'agente qui a exprimé son
mécontentement nous serons à conakry
dans ce journal
l'afrique du sud menacés par les criques
et il s'agit de l'invasion la plus
destructrice en 25 ans les agriculteurs
de trois provinces se bat contre le
fléau alors qu'ils sortent tout juste
d'une sécheresse de 7 ans reportage dans
un instant
labinal d'art d'afrique contemporain afd
dov africain contemporain de dakar
l'événement a ouvert ses portes ce jeudi
la 14e édition accueille jusqu'au 21
juin le meilleur de la création
contemporaine du continent notre
correspondante à dakar sarah sakho a
fait pour nous l'exposition principale
juste avant le coup d'envoi officiel
reportage à sion et puis ce soir nous
recevons sur notre plateau la star de
l'afro funk l'artiste franco congolais
bonne foi ni auteur compositeur
interprète il vient nous présenter son
dernier album cosmogonie qui sort demain
d'ailleurs entretien à la fin de ce
journal
les autorités guinéennes n'ont pas
manqué d'exprimer leur mécontentement
la cedeao a rejeté la transition de 36
mois proposée par les militaires au
pouvoir une durée de transition
également rejeté par une grande partie
de l'opposition
la correspondance à conakry de manille
diakité au coeur de cette conférence de
presse la menace de manifestations de
rue des principaux partis politiques de
la société civile à mais aussi et
surtout les réactions à la durée de la
transition porté à 36 mois par le
conseil national de la transition
jean-claude cas si brou président de la
commission de la cedeao affirme aurait
jeté les 36 mois comme durée de la
transition une réaction que les
militaires au pouvoir ne digère pas nous
sommes dans une tradition qui m'est
beaucoup d'attention et 7 abstentions
voudrais que nous fassions fassions
attention tout ce que nous pouvons dire
par là spécifiquement de monsieur brou
je ne pense pas même la vie qui soit la
bonne personne pour donner ses leçons de
respect ou de quoi que ce soit à la
dînette et la mesure où le même enjeu
parce que son mandat est à questionner
rapport à la cedeao pour le porte parole
du gouvernement de transition le débat
ne devrait pas porter sur la durée de la
transition nous avons une durée de
mandat au lait de pile au gué sur la
validité ou non commençons à dérouler
les étapes devant permettre le sortir de
cette transition on a besoin d'un
fichier électoral accepté de tous
on a besoin de toilettage institutionnel
et législatif
on a besoin de dérouler un calendrier
électoral pour sortir de l'intelligence
et trois étapes la somme nécessaire
elles sont pas contestables qui que ce
soit à signaler que les militaires au
pouvoir reste ferme sur la décision
d'interdiction de manifestations de rue
dans le pays une décision dénoncée par
les ong de défense des droits de l'homme
et puis sachez qu'une délégation de la
cedeao a été également dépêché ce jeudi
en mission à ouagadougou au burkina faso
une délégation conduite entre autres par
le président de la commission de
l'organisation ouest africaine jean
claude broult objectif se prononcer sur
la durée de la transition fixée par les
militaires au pouvoir dans le pays
l'afrique du sud subit l'invasion de
criquets et la plus destructrice en 25
ans les agriculteurs de trois provinces
se bat contre le fléau alors qu'ils
sortent tout juste d'une sécheresse de 7
ans le gouvernement sud-africain des
jaloux et 5 millions d'euros pour les
aider reportage de caroline dumay
la province du cap oriental sort de
l'une des sécheresses les plus long de
son histoire mais les premières pluies
tombées à peine qu'une autre catastrophe
est arrivée
regardez ils enlèvent le peu d'herbe que
nous avons la famille de cameron possède
des terres dans la région depuis 1820
mais ils n'ont jamais vu une telle
explosion de cris qui envoya que là où
ils sont passés en une terre
complètement sèche ils font tous
disparaître tout ce qui est nutritifs
laisse juste les petites branches
les criquets sont descendus pendant deux
mois l'année dernière dans ses pâturages
il a vu six moutons mourir de faim
cameron est très inquiet pour les verts
qui arrive
[Musique]
on a perdu 3 à 4000 hectares de champs
l'an dernier le gouvernement doit
réaliser que si ça continue comme ça on
va se retrouver avec une crise
alimentaire sur les bras
le gouvernement sud africain prend
progressivement la mesure du désastre
pour enrayer le fléau il a nommé dans
chaque province des officiers comme
cette volontaire qui a pour mission de
suivre les essaims qui se propage dans
sa province et de distribuer les
produits insecticides fournis par l'état
à partir du moment où ils sont là il est
déjà trop tard pour les contrôler avec
la chaleur le poison s'évapore et n'a
plus autant d'effets sur les criques et
ses volontaires interviennent parfois en
une seule journée dans une quarantaine
d'endroits différents il arrive au petit
matin quand les criquets sont encore au
sol et avant qu'ils ne s'envolent les
pesticides utilisés tue instantanément
les insectes mais ils n'ont pas d'impact
sur les oeufs qui vont éclore dès les
premières pluies de l'été
le responsable du principal syndicat
agricole de la région explique que
l'aide gouvernementale est insuffisante
et qu'il faudrait déclaré l'état
d'urgence
on ne peut pas avoir de changement aussi
d'un de nos méthodes agricoles sans
conséquences économiques
des sécheresses aux plus diluvienne les
changements climatiques ont de plus en
plus d'impact en afrique du sud
dans le reste de l'actualité en bref et
en images la pelle alarmant de l'onu
pour sauver la corne de l'afrique
l'organisation internationale demande
une aide financière immédiate pour
soutenir cette région très durement
frappées par la sécheresse plus de 18
millions de personnes sont touchées et
la situation va probablement s'aggraver
dans les semaines à venir
pierre emerick aubameyang l'attaquant
gabonais ou fc barcelone a annoncé qu'il
mettait fin à sa carrière internationale
une annonce par la voix de patrice neveu
le sélectionneur des panthères
information confirmée par la fédération
gabonaise de football et puis pour le
mondial 2022 au qatar six femmes figure
pour la première fois sur la liste des
cent cinq arbitres parmi elles la
rwandaise salima mot candanga elle avait
déjà été la première femme à arbitrer en
coupe d'afrique des nations aucun boon
en janvier dernier
la biennale d'art africain contemporain
de dakar s'est ouverte ce jeudi après
midi après un report en 2020 à cause du
copic 19 la 14e édition accueille
jusqu'au 21 juin le meilleur de la
création contemporaine du continent les
artistes sont heureux de pouvoir exposer
leurs oeuvres les participants sont
originaires de plus de 80 pays mais la
biennale mais les artistes d'afrique et
sa diaspora à l'honneur sarah sakho
notre correspondante est allé visiter
l'exposition principale international
juste avant le coup d'envoi officiel
reportage
derniers préparatifs avant le lancement
officiel de la biennale
59 artistes participent à l'exposition
principale qui se tient dans l'ancien
palais de justice de la ville
le camerounais a qu à auxonne
s'interroge sur la place des rites
ancestraux dans l'afrique contemporaine
fally senso plasticiens du sénégal a
imaginé un monde futur des plus
inquiétants
victor sauna lui vient de hollande et
explore ces identités multiples en
jouant avec les matériaux comme ça
qu'ils soient à boycotter
le tableau
comme nombre d'artistes invités le
plasticien né au cameroun expose
principalement en europe il vit cette
expérience comme un retour aux sources
très appréciée
respiration chez les femmes en afrique
pourquoi pas cessé la buzelle cerruti
tous ces expirations consorts et puis
c'est génial de gagner là-bas poulet
pour les remonter ce que j'ai fait ce
que j'ai pu
mener la barque
pour le directeur artistique de la
biennale ce rendez vous initié il ya
plus de 30 ans est un véritable
baromètre de l'évolution de la
créativité africaine c'est une biennale
qui se concentre sur les réalités
artistiques du continent et de ses
diasporas donc c'est pas une biennale
internationale dans le sens où
tout le monde va la priorité cette ville
est ouverte mais la priorité c'est les
artistes du continent pour le donner un
espace de visibilité afin de promouvoir
la paire
2500 artistes au total prenne part à
cette manifestation à travers le
programme officiel qui compte une
quinzaine d'expositions mais surtout en
participant au off de cette biennale qui
s'exposent sur 450 sites dans la
capitale sénégalaise et même dans
plusieurs autres villes du pays
et comme promis on va finir en beauté et
en musique avec bantunani l'artiste
franco franco-congolais la star de
l'afro funk est notre invité ce soir
bonsoir merci des chenilles sommes venus
nous présenter votre dernier album vous
décrivez ce nouvel opus comme un voyage
cosmique qu'est ce que cela veut dire
d'ailleurs et ça s'appelle cosmogonie
cosmogonie ça sera très ce titre
condensé dans la profusion à savoir soul
funk groove et surtour obésité ma
musique depuis treize albums s'invente
et sa bande son c'est donc c
deux sont deux années de réflexion de
travail approfondi avec des nouveaux
musiciens et mes enfants et surtout
montré redonner un peu d'espérance à ce
monde qui en a beaucoup besoin alors le
clip pigalle swing est sorti aujourd'hui
on va écouter un extrait merci
[Musique]
non
m
ça vaut
[Musique]
alors pourquoi cet hommage au célèbre
quartier de paris c'est avant tout un
hommage à fresnes cette chanteuse oublié
mais inoubliable
parce que le monde a besoin de légèreté
c'est pour rappeler que paris qui ne
fait que la ville peut peut et doit
rester une fête et surtout je trouve que
cette chanteuse et à disparaître
conscience collectif et dont j'avais
besoin de deux masses purell cet univers
un peu cabaret jazz pour une chanson je
manquais de refrain je me suis dit tiens
qu'est ce qu'il ya dans la java bleue
c'était trop trop lointain j'ai choisi
nous poussons des années vous avez vous
aimé mélanger tous ces genres musicaux
on le fait depuis depuis très longtemps
mais pour moi la musique comme une
rencontre c'est comme cuisiner c'est il
faut ajouter les ingrédients mélangés
recherche sans cesse et pour faire un
bon voyage cosmique il faut voyager avec
les autres alors vous avez justement
travaillé avec le producteur américain
qui jay retourne automne qui a notamment
travaillé avec rihanna et nicki minaj
qu'est ce qu'il a apporté à votre album
cela petite touche hip hop
durant ce confinement le problème c'est
qu'une artiste au centre beaucoup isolé
seul et donc ça fait deux ans que ce
soit avec twitter c'est fikara mais nous
ça mouettes qui apporte aussi une touche
importante c'est à la fois ceux à notre
regard sur l'artiste dont c'est la foire
relativiser le travail qui est souvent
très lourds de l'artiste et surtout
apporter au cse sons électroniques et
parfois juste la petite touche aussi du
succès du heat alors votre titre
francophile évoque le rendez vous a
manqué de la france avec l'afp en
francophonie francofolies alors j'en
profite car ce que je vois que les
petites polémiques sur la chanson mais
dont je tiens à dire c'est une chanson
de fraternité dans laquelle je
m'interroge où est passée la
francophonie heureuse à savoir
l'alliance des peuples autour la
francophonie autour d'alain française et
qu' il faut voir l'afrique comme une
commune terreau de ressources non pas
comme les terres de parfois deux
on le comprend et on essaye de le
montrer ici dans le journal de l'afrique
j'aimerais savoir aussi qu est-ce qui
vous ainsi qu'est ce qui vous a inspiré
le plus dans ce dernier album vous savez
les tons passé durant deux années de
confinement la guerre actuelle donc
moi je fais comme un ami dans tous les
deux ans sort un album j'observe le
monde je marche je cours entre orléans
paris nice et beaucoup cannes pour cette
période si
l'observation surtout la vie de la
littérature c'est paradoxal la
littérature ma porte parfois beaucoup de
réflexion est donc dans mon enfant kung
fu lee en l'occurrence c'est un peu au
passé victor hugo où est passé le
combalou de l'ordre vous de la recherche
à la recherche de la francophonie je
pourrais dire
est ce que le monde dit le monde
m'inspire est ce que le monde et ce qui
se passe en ce moment vous inspire
beaucoup pour un prochain album est-ce
que c'est des inspirations plutôt
positivement le texte dont leur
cosmogonie c'est sa cosmogonie qu'est-ce
que quelques la cosmogonie l'avancement
boigny c'est je propose de retrouver une
conscience
j'ai aucune idée que la conscience le
moins que la cosmogonie sur legrand nous
il ya des choses qui nous lie qui sont
très fortes le éléments invisibles
l'humanité il faut il faut koné
conscience de la violence tom qu'on ne
regarde plus tellement de manière assez
assez anthropologique mais qui est
vraiment d'une violence il faut passer
au delà de ça il faut dépasser at
relations humaines il faut voyager tous
ensemble se préparer à d'autres vies que
les ce que c'est que ces formes
matérielles ou d'être c est je pense une
came urgence et dans next generation
quand je chante on doit réfléchir à la
génération c'est pas les générations
futures c'est nous actuellement nous en
tant que vos journalistes - chanteur
c'est le toit les temps sont graves il
faut à la fois épousé la musique chantée
lieu sûr du groupe mais garder cette
forme de conscience
ne jamais faire la musique n'ont jamais
chanté l'idiot et garder l'espérance on
savoir que la parole les montants sens
nous sommes des poètes plus ou moins
déguisés ou avérés il faut savoir que
les mots dont je lis au rapport à la
génération et du retrait avec moi les
moindres un sens on nous sommes des gens
responsables
quelle est l'urgence pour parler des
urgences si vous deviez en cité où seuls
sur le continent africain
trouver des dirigeants et non plus des
dirigeables
merci beaucoup bon tout n'a ni merci
d'être venu nous présenter votre dernier
album cosmogonie qui sort demain je le
rappelle merci infiniment de nous avoir
accordé de votre temps pour venir
chercher une photo c'est la fin du
journal de l'afrique rester avec nous
l'info continue sur france 24
[Musique]
non
oh